gilles rémy homme d'affaires qui a su
tisser un lien tout particulier avec la
russie tout au long de sa carrière
rebonjour gilles rémy merci d'être une
nouvelle fois avec nous sur rt france
pour évoquer est ce défilé ces
célébrations du 9 mai vous qui avez vécu
en russie qu'est ce que ça représente ce
9 mai pour les russes je crois que c'est
le fait c'est assez la grande fête
nationale russe qui a ressoudé tout un
tout un peuple et tout un pays et même
qui était à l'époque soviétique qui
était en quelque sorte la pierre sur
laquelle reposait cette cette union je
le disais tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui c'est le 9 mai est fêté dans
l'ensemble presque dans l'ensemble des
anciennes républiques socialistes
soviétiques
c'est un grand jour ac c'est l'un des
plus grands sacrifices qu une quinte
qu'une nation ait pu et plus et puis de
données pour une c'est une guerre
j'étais il ya maurice leroy parler de ce
talent égal nous y étions effectivement
il ya deux semaines c'était la deuxième
fois que je me rendais et à chaque fois
c'est une émotion qui est intacte et on
mesure on mesure quand on est sur place
ce sacrifice humain mais aussi cette
organisation qui a permis de battre la
première la première armée du monde qui
était la larme les nazis on a vu un ces
célébrations du 9 mer énorme défilé
militaire on n'a pas l'habitude de voir
ce genre d'image en france comment
expliquer justement ce décalage entre
les célébrations en russie
en occident il ya plusieurs facteurs il
ya d'une part
historiquement ce que tout ce que
représente le ce mais cette victoire
d'exceptionnel héroïque de la deuxième
guerre mondiale on l'a dit d'autres
interlocuteurs on dit le poids militaire
le poète démographique delà des
sacrifices de la delà de la russie mais
il ya aussi je crois une volonté
aujourd'hui de montrer que la russie
après avoir été terriblement affaibli
dans les années 90 est une grande
puissance et que la russie
on a vu un défilé militaire qu on ne va
pas commenter d'un point de vue
technique mais imaginons aujourd'hui que
la russie en pratiquement la parité dans
la plupart des domaines peut être hors
la marine avec les états unis sur les
temps avec des états unis décombres a
craint cette fois plus d'argent à leur
complexe militaro-industriel que je
rappelle aussi qu'elle soit en ce qui
concerne le budget de la russie en ce
qui concerne le talent et pourtant la
russie est au premier plan technologique
moi je vous assure que dans les années
90 quand on a vu délabrement
l'effondrement de deux étages n'aurais
pas parié un kopeck sur la capacité du
complexe militaro industriel de revenir
un jour au premier plan alors évidemment
c'est dans une période de crise
internationale d' de la relation de
l'europe des états unis avec la russie
parce que je crois qu'il s'agit bien de
l'occident la russie a d'excellentes
relations avec l'asie avec la chine mais
avec l'afrique avec l'amérique latine
donc dans cette période de confrontation
effectivement c'est un message la russie
est une est un grand pays sur lequel il
faut compter dans le monde et je crois
qu'il une fierté certainement très
naturelle de la part des ruches de voir
qu'ils comptent à nouveau le monde je
posais la question tout à leurs agents
de glee
un ch'ti 1 vous qui avez vécu en russie
en quoi votre avis la france a tout
intérêt à entretenir de bonnes relations
avec la russie en interne
tout simplement parce que ça correspond
à nos intérêts nationaux
nous n'avons rien qui nous qui nous
amènerait à à être en situation de
contentieux avec la russie la russie en
termes économiques ne nous pose aucun
préjudice
on n'assiste pas à des délocalisations
de notre industrie comme ce que ça peut
être le cas avec la chine
donc ce n'est pas un concurrent
pratiquement économique au contraire
c'est un partenaire et puis il ya aussi
des actes à d'intérêt commun a
aujourd'hui alors que notre industrie
nucléaire a menacé la russie est
redevenu un des pays majeurs et notre
intérêt mutuel
effectivement c'est de faire en sorte
que le nucléaire ne soit pas effacer de
nos mixte énergétique
donc en fait objectivement il n'y a pas
de raison je crois que les raisons cette
étape peut à ces cétacés est d'ailleurs
unique dans l'histoire et les tiennent
peut-être plus à un conflit qui devient
un conflit idéologique alors c'est que
le capitalisme contre le socialisme
aujourd'hui c'est une forme de ces la
souveraineté contre le mondialisme
c est la souveraineté sous tous ses
aspects c'est la souveraineté politique
la souveraineté diplomatique la
souveraineté économique et également la
russie a évolué aujourd'hui dallas la
situation là la vision qu'ont les
dirigeants russes n'a plus grand chose à
voir avec celle qu'on a pu connaître
dans les années 90 avec avec helsinn
donc aujourd'hui je pense que c'est la
russie montre le mauvais exemple à
l'europe qui elle est sur des bases
idéologiques et sur un projet qui est
qui est complètement différente c'est à
dire là le fait de passer au delà des
nations pour construire quelque chose
d'autre si vous avez écouté avec nous le
résident vladimir poutine qui parlait de
vue du souvenir qui parlait des vétérans
de l'hommage que l'on devait rendre aux
vétérans la notion de souvenirs elle est
importante en russie
oui la notion souvenirs et est important
que non seulement parce que le il s'agit
comme on l'a dit d'un du nom d'une
guerre est exceptionnel et dans sa dans
son ampleur ne se leurre mais également
parce que les russes ont un sens aigü
l'histoire c'est à dire que là on n'a
pas assisté à une à une destruction de
l'histoire la et écoute il a réussi à
faire quelque chose d'assez exceptionnel
c'est à dire une forme de syncrétisme et
de et d'intégrer un roman national est
ce que nous l'avions d'ailleurs a connu
et qui va de des tsars des empereurs en
passant par par la période soviétique le
rôle de staline etc qui est une analyse
qui est aussi critique sur leur sur un
cynisme mais qui intègre toutes les
époques et toutes les générations en ce
qui concerne l'histoire contemporaine
dans un passé un passé et un passé pour
avoir un avenir commun donc les livres
d'histoire des écoles russes sont des
livres qui ressemble un petit peu à ceux
des années soixante ou soixante dix en
france c'est à dire qu'on a une arme aux
gens je reprends terme un roman national
qui intègre toutes les époques et qui
donne effectivement une profondeur
historique que l'argent et sera la
population russe qui est un peu
différent le en occident et en france
particulièrement jean rémy on a suivi
ensemble sur les antennes d'ayrté france
ce matin entre 9h et 10h cet immense
défilé militaire qui est lui je le
rappelle sur la place rouge comme tous
les ans le 9 mai sauf l'année dernière
pour raisons sanitaires on était donc à
moscou mais la russie c'est un pays
excessivement grand est ce que vous
savez ce qui se passe ce jour là dans
les autres villes du pays
oui c'est ce qui se passe il se passe
que dans chaque heure chaque village
dans chaque ville de russie aujourd'hui
c'est un 7-1 c'est un grand tour et les
gens sont dans la rue et les gens vont
au monument aux morts
et puis les gens dans chaque famille il
y aller les familles se retrouvent et
c'est un repas un repas de fête et de
souvenirs
est ce assez on n'a pas la même si beau
ce trou et parfois différent du du pays
profond l année c'est certainement une
des choses qui est mieux partagée
aujourd'hui c'est la commémoration d'une
hausse mais dans toute la russie
comme je disais aussi lors d'une grande
partie de l'ex union soviétique
on a parlé tout à l'heure de la parade
des immortels
cette parade ou où justement les les
rues stand des panneaux avec des photos
de leurs ancêtres des cd ou qui ont subi
cette seconde guerre mondiale ça aussi
cette parade des immortels c'est un
symbole est ce que vous avez à vous y
allez assister vous oui j'ai participé à
plusieurs reprises et je pense était là
problème la première ou la deuxième met
donc vous imaginez dans dans moscou sur
la rue thiers callas ou vont défiler les
chars tout à l'heure vous avez après la
parade militaire
des milliers des centaines de milliers
de gens qui se réunissent sous tentes
aliments et on n'est pas dans une
dans une démonstration pendant des
manifestations du 1er mai soviétique où
il y avait par entreprise
un contingent qui étaient déterminés là
les gens reviennent ne viennent pas mais
les gens viennent et est ce qui est très
très très marquant c'est effectivement
c'est que vous avez toutes les
générations
toutes les générations et les enfants et
les enfants porteurs de des photos des
portraits de leur arrière grand père
c'est quelque chose de très le 13
novembre et sera l'ami tout à l'heure
ses traits marquants et surtout pour
nous français parce que on a en a le
sentiment d'avoir perdu cette capacité à
2,2 de nous réunir ensemble pour pour
comme noé
toutes générations confondues et ça
c'est le groupe à on parlait tout à
l'heure de effectivement de l'histoire
du sens de l'histoire c'est cet insigne
un signe très très très fort et je
rappelle cette initiative delà du
bataillon des immortels est une
initiative au départ l'initiative privée
qui est mais qui a correspondait
soixante dix ans après qui correspond
encore est belle et plus que jamais à ce
que ressentent les russes c'est à dire
une grande fierté et pour leur histoire
nationale
on le disait un peu de diplomate et peu
de chefs d'état étrangers on assistait
ce à se défier comment on peut on peut
l'expliquer raisons sanitaires
diplomatique les deux je crois que c'est
un peu les deux le de la pandémie
justifie beaucoup de choses l'année
dernière on avait on avait beaucoup
espéré on attendait la musique du
président du président français ça ne
s'est pas fait pour principalement pour
des raisons des raisons sanitaires
aujourd'hui il n'y avait qu'un seul
président étranger c'était présidente
rakhmanov au plus tôt mettant harmon du
tadjikistan cela étant ce n'est pas ça
ne suffit pas que la réussite soit isolé
comme je le disais delà de l'asie de
l'afrique ou d'aider des anciens des
anciens pays
j'aurais quand même dire un petit mot
quand même ce qui n'est pas ce rapport
au discours de deux petites blessures la
résurgence d'idéologie mais je pense
qu'il avait quand même en tête ce qui se
passe en ukraine ce qui est très
douloureux non seulement pour les
ukrainiens mais pour les russes c'est
cette se laisser faire du régime au
pouvoir en ukraine en verre ce qui est
la résurgence de teint d'une
collaboration et d'asie j'étais très
très choqué de voir que la dernière
manifestation néo nazis en faveur du
régiment les waffen ss galicie qui a eu
à kiev ya quinze jours n'a pas du tout
été évoquée par là par la presse
française l'occidentale en général parce
que ça gêne parce que là elle à
l'ukraine et est notre alliée dans une
dans un engin dans un combat pour
affaiblir la la la russie c'est un
calcul stupide à mon sens mais on ne
doit pas laisser passer les chaussures
de sacs tous les russes savent très bien
ça paraisse dans l'est dans l'est dans
les journaux télévisés ce qui se passe
en ukraine alors c'est pas là que le
pays entier qui risque de tomber dans la
dans un néo nazisme mais c'est
insupportable insupportable que dd
monument sera érigé à d'anciens
collaborateurs nazis
et puis c'est insupportable que par
exemple si c'était le sixième
anniversaire du massacre d'odessa qu'en
plus de 40 personnes ont été brûlées
vives à la maison des syndicats où elle
a dit nations étrangères l'a dit nation
et lagnieu parti en ukraine et en russie
et donc c'est ce deux poids deux mesures
qui qui est assez choquant et je pense
que c'était ça qui ne fait qu il fallait
voir aussi dans la résurgence de ce
d'idéologie néo nazis au kiss et 8 dont
par des coutumes dans son discours
gilles rémy j'aimerais revenir avec vous
sur cette journée du 9 mai sur ce sur ce
défilé sur ces célébrations
vous qui avez vécu longtemps en russie
vous avez également été décoré de
l'ordre de l'amitié par vladimir poutine
il ya quatre ans maintenant d'en parler
avec jean de gliniasty tout à l'heure
lui qui était ambassadeur il ressentait
justement cette volonté des russes de
vouloir nouer des relations avec la
france
est ce que c'est ce que vous avez
ressenti vous aussi quand vous étiez sur
place
ah oui bien sûr c'est ça c'est une
constante de la 2d russe du peuple russe
et a sali la france et de ses le pays
c'est le pays le plus aimé à l'étranger
c'est pour des raisons de culture
d'histoire là la france a aidé a été
admiré
je dirais que l'évolution c'est que
peut-être que là nous avons été admirés
tête au delà de ce que nous pouvions
être et que aujourd'hui les russes qui
connaissent mieux la france que les
français ne connaissent la russie
aujourd'hui sont terriblement déçue
déçue par quand ils viennent en visite
en france par là peut-être la saleté de
paris mais également par l'attitude
qu'ils ont sur sur l'avenir l'avenir de
nos de notre pays ça va très très bien
l'actualité l'actualité française et il
y as est cet attachement qu'ils ont à la
france fait que certainement la russie
et à des prix ils souffrent plus de nous
de notre difficulté pour lui vous avez
entendu lorsqu'il s'est dit sur cette
place rouge à moscou on parlait juste
avant des relations franco-russes vous
qui avez vous longtemps vécu en russie
qui avaient beaucoup échangé avec les
russes racontez nous un petit peu quel
était le genre de relation que vous
entretenez avec avec nos amis russes
je ne parlerais pour passer parce que je
suis toujours un acteur la coopération
économique entre les deux pays
le le le nous avons vécu au cours des 10
15 dernières années de très très grands
moments en termes de coopération que ce
soit dans le secteur nucléaire que ce
soit souvenez vous aussi dans le secteur
de la défense ces fameux mistral qui ont
été un exemple extraordinaire de
coopération industrielle militaire et
politique et je crois que la rupture
effectivement il ya eu un moment
une étape que extrêmement négative qui
était qui était passé quand le président
hollande a décidé de ne pas livrer les
bateaux qui étaient construits qui avait
été payée et de ne pas les livrer alors
que juridiquement étaient mêmes
diplomatiquement rien ne nous obligeait
à renoncer à ce contrat puisqu'il avait
été signé avant les sanctions
européennes
suite au rattachement de la crimée à la
russie à partir de ce moment là
effectivement il ya une rupture une
perte de confiance puisque aussi
s'agissait il n'y a pas de précédent à
ce genre de renonciation aujourd'hui la
coopération continue et les mêmes
importante à français est un des
principaux investisseurs occidentaux en
russie le premier employé employeur
étranger et donc nous avons aujourd'hui
des entreprises la plupart des
entreprises du cac 40 mais aussi des
centaines d'entreprises qui sont
présentes à moscou et je veux dire que
le rôle joué par par les entreprises
dans la relation bilatérale est
extrêmement important on n'avait jamais
connu la la halle et le monde des
affaires à l'époque soviétique
les échanges étaient relativement
limitées et il y avait c'était plutôt
chez les politiques qu'il y avait une
expertise de la russie je n'en fais
partis politiques il y avait des gens
qui connaissaient très très très bien et
qu'ils avaient des contacts personnels
avec des des personnalités soviétiques
et russes aujourd'hui je dirais que nous
avons en affaiblissant terrible de la
connaissance réelle de ce qu'est la
russie
dans le monde politique français et
heureusement heureusement la le monde
économique très très présent en russie à
maintien c'est ce ce dialogue et s'est
échangé on se souvient à la mort de
jacques chirac
la dmr poutine peiné de la mordue de
l'ancien président français les deux
hommes s'entendaient bien les deux
hommes s'étaient vus plusieurs fois
vladimir poutine avait même dit qu'ils
avaient été impressionnés par la culture
du président français est ce que
justement à l'époque de jacques chirac
on a vécu une hégémonie des relations
franco russes oui on a vécu on était
dans une période de très bonne entente
de très bonne compréhension
là il faut dire que la politique
américaine et européenne était et est
beaucoup plus modérée qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui donc le contexte était quand
même beaucoup plus favorable laissée
d'une marge de manoeuvre plus importante
il faut bien souligner que dans il ya
une forme de continuité avec la
présidence sarkozy qui était
certainement les 6,5 années ont été
marquées par de très grandes avancées
dans le domaine de la coopération
économique
il y avait pris à l'époque de sa cousine
souvenons nous que le le prédisaient que
poutine n'était pas et n'est pas
président il était premier ministre et
son son interlocuteur de travail était
françois fillon et est donc ce qui a
amené les deux hommes d'ailleurs très
bien se connaître et à travailler des
dossiers d'une manière très approfondie
et ces années ont été marquées est
effectivement là la symbolique sera la
décision française de coopérer pour la
première fois à cette échelle dans le
secteur de la coopération militaro
industriel en construisant les mistral
sur les chantiers navals de saint
nazaire
donc on a eu effectivement dans l'art
dans la lah la prolongation dans
l'impulsion qui avait été donnée par
jacques chirac
on a eu jusqu'à la présidence et
hollande d année faste en termes de
de coopération merci beaucoup gilles
rémy d'avoir été avec nous tout au long
de cette matinée pour commenter ensemble
et analyser cette 76ème cérémonie du
jour de la victoire merci beaucoup à
vous on